what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder happy
thanksgiving to everybody who is
celebrating that today and thank you to
everyone for supporting my channel i
super super appreciate it now just
because it's thanksgiving doesn't mean
that the spider-man news stops of course
not we have new spider-man posters
posters that i think a lot of people are
going to like a bit more than the ones
we got in the past and also today we
have some news about that charlie cox
matt murdock daredevil scene and
spider-man no way home i know a lot of
people are really looking forward to
that matt murdock scene and we're gonna
talk about what you can expect from that
scene in this video like i said we have
three new posters today here's one of
them this is just kind of a generic one
but i think fans are really going to
like the three that they have a lot
better than the old ones at least this
one shows doctor strange and peter in
the mirror dimension we can see the city
in the background is upside down now
i'll admit this is the lesser of the
three we're definitely talking about the
other two but first before we get
started big thank you to established
titles for sponsoring this video this
one's actually really cool and very
personal to me because i've actually
used established titles before my family
is from scotland and they do a lot of
great work for the environment with
established titles you can officially
become a lord or a lady and when i say
that i literally mean it you can change
your name to lord or lady and get it on
your credit cards or plane tickets and
you get an official certificate here's
mine i'm technically lord warren
thompson but y'all can still call me
cosmic in scotland if you own a piece of
land you are referred to as lord or lady
through established titles you get one
square foot of land in scotland which
will officially make you a lord or a
lady and the best part is in return they
plant a tree with every order to protect
the beautiful pristine woodlands of
scotland christmas is coming up and this
makes for the perfect christmas gift or
a last minute gift for somebody's
birthday they're also doing a black
friday sale which is ten percent off and
buy one get one free this is a great
cause and a great gift for yourself or a
loved one and you can get ten percent
off if you go to establishtitles.com
cosmic
so two more posters and the second one
gets better the third one is obviously
the best save the best for last but the
second one does get better the second
one is of spider-man and doctor strange
coming out of a portal from a sling ring
and i think you'll find that some pretty
interesting things happen with sling
rings and spider-man no way home like
how a certain other two spider-men show
up wink wink but in this poster they're
going out of the portal and they're
going to fight doc ock and for those of
you who may be wondering about that
release date it is releasing on the 16th
in some countries it's releasing on the
15th in some countries the 17th and some
others also keep in mind like for
instance here in the u.s it comes out
the 17th but you can actually buy
tickets to watch it on the 16th so be
aware of that when you buy your tickets
for it on spider monday now like i said
this poster is better than the first but
the last one is by far the best poster
that we've got for spider-man no way
home yet this poster right here shows
spider-man doctor strange zendaya's mj
and if you look in the upper right which
seems to be a theme with the posters we
have green goblin but he's not in his
normal suit if you zoom in you can see
that this is a comic accurate green
goblin he is not wearing his green
goblin helmet but in fact he is wearing
his hood now we had plenty of plot leaks
come out way before the first trailer
even came out telling us that the green
goblin was going to be more comic
accurate and that he was going to be
wearing his hood for most of the movie
yes he would come in with his helmet but
they were going for a comic accurate
green goblin and as we can see here and
as we briefly saw in the main trailer a
hooded kind of purplish green colored
green goblin and this poster actually
shows all five of the villains and for
those of you who have been asking i
don't think there's going to be a sixth
villain i've talked about this a little
bit in some of my videos but it looks
like sony is planning on doing a
sinister six project a separate project
so they don't want a true full sinister
six showing up in spiderman no way home
they don't want people to call these
villains the sinister six because
apparently there are going to be
different villains a part of a true
sinister six that's the word going
around right now so no we're not gonna
get a sixth villain but this poster does
show five villains and we can see jamie
foxx's electro in the middle there and
it looks like he's really only going to
be blue looking like he did in the
amazing spider-man 2 for just a little
bit in spider-man home probably right
when he gets into our universe then he's
gonna find that stark reactor which is
pretty crazy cool to think about he's
gonna use that to kind of harness all of
this energy and he's going to be a
normal looking person actually he's
gonna be better than that he's going to
be a comic accurate electro in fact all
of these villains are looking pretty
dang comic accurate and you have to
applaud marvel studios and sony for that
in this film so we have elektra there in
the middle and we can see his
electricity kind of forming a circle
around with the sling ring which looks
pretty cool onto the right of him of
course we can see the lizard we've
gotten some really good shots of the
lizard recently and he looks pretty good
and he looks comic accurate and i'm
really hoping they do these two
characters elektro and the lizard more
justice than they did them in the
amazing spider-man franchise the same
goes with andrew garfield i think he's a
great spider-man and i hope he gets a
better chance to prove himself in this
movie now a little bit above electro and
the lizard we can see sand it looks like
sand storms but of course we know that
it's the sandman and of course the
common theme of most of the trailers tv
spots posters is doc ock's arms it's
tentacle arms they're all over this
poster and they're trying to make you
think that doc ock is going to be the
main villain but i actually don't think
he is going to be according to what i've
heard the green goblin is definitely the
main villain of this film in fact i
wouldn't be surprised if doc ock
actually turned somewhat good during
this film now some people may not like
that but remember he did turn good at
the end of spider-man 2. and it does
seem like his arms are kind of in
control again so maybe if he gets
control over them at some point in time
in this movie he'll be good again and
maybe even help spider-man all of the
spider-man take on green goblin and the
rest of the villains or maybe he'll just
be evil now he died before now he has a
chance to live again so that could kind
of change you a little bit we'll have to
wait and see but now let's talk about
that matt murdock scene that i know a
lot of people are very curious about now
there were some leaked photos that went
around not too long ago they were posted
by john campia because he believed them
to be fake and i do believe him on that
part because i don't think he would have
posted them if he thought they were real
he's in tight with a lot of studios i
don't think he'd want to piss anybody
off however he took the photos down
because he heard that they are probably
real and one of those photos is peter
parker aunt may happy hogan sitting at a
dinner table with one other person and
that other person in this picture is
matt murdock now let's go back to an
interview that tom holland did where he
said that there's this truly awesome
scene where him aunt may happy and
another person are sitting down at a
table talking about what it's like to be
superheroes originally i myself and a
lot of people thought that this would be
toby mcguire or andrew garfield but it
looks like it's going to be matt murdock
now i've been told that he doesn't
really have that much time in this movie
it's very quick one scene maybe two but
the scene that we get here is what tom
was talking about with a little bit more
to it according to daniel rpk who does
now have a youtube channel if you want
to follow him for some inside scoops
matt murdock and peter are going to be
talking and matt murdock's saying that
he's going to get everything taken care
of and that peter parker is going to be
all right peter then asks how and at
this moment somebody throws a brick
through the window then matt murdock
reaches out catches it out of the air
puts it down and says i'm a really good
lawyer and this is going to be our first
nod and hint that matt murdock is
daredevil in the mcu it's recently been
reported that daredevil is going to be
cameoing in three different projects and
then getting his own solo project and
spider-man nowy home is going to be the
first start of his cameos and peter will
probably start to kind of see that matt
murdock may be a little bit more super
than he thought a blind person randomly
grabbing a brick out of the middle of
the air to protect people and based off
of everything i heard that is the scene
that we are going to be getting with
matt murdock slash daredevil and
spider-man knowing home so let me know
what you think about this scene in the
comments down below let me know what you
think about the posters which one is
your favorite they just released last
night and i'm assuming on monday spider
monday we are going to be getting
something cool a new tv spot a clip of
spiderman no way home possibly a final
trailer so have your eyes open be on the
lookout for that also still doing my
spiderman collectible giveaway to enter
all you have to do subscribe to my
channel and the channel cosmic culture
and leave some comments on some recent
videos the giveaway ends at the end of
this month only a handful of days left
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram twitter or tic tac and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof